Right.
Thank you for coming. I'm impressed. Uh,
and flattered that you'd come. Number
one to hear me. And number two,
uh,
I mentioned to mark earlier,
the world would come to a
screeching halt without Google.
I'm just pretty convinced of that.
We are all so dependent now on Google
so it's actually pretty have much of an
honor to be here to talk to you.
What I want to do is talk to you a little
bit about the work we're doing at the
university and we have
a research center there.
And I want to share with you some
of what I think is important for
organizations,
for leaders and maybe for parents and
friends and colleagues even that is a,
I want to talk to you about the power
of and the importance of positive
leadership,
positive practices,
positive dynamics for individuals
and for organizations. So,
um,
I want to have you think
about align across this slide
as representing a deviant
continuum now in English that we're,
deviants has a negative connotation.
So normally deviance means you're in
trouble, you're doing something wrong.
If I call you a deviant,
normally a criticism,
but deviants just means an
aberration from the norm. Unexpected,
not normal behavior show.
There's several implications of
thinking of deviants on a continuum,
so you can think of negative deviance,
but you can also think
of positive deviance.
Several implications,
one of which is all organizations
exist to eliminate deviance.
The reason we organize just to eliminate
unexpected abberant not normal behavior.
So mark stands up, everybody stops
talking, everybody looks forward.
We organize, otherwise it's
chaos. We can't get anything done.
Show all organizations aspire
by definition toward the
middle of that continuum.
That is, we don't want deviance,
unexpected aberrant behavior.
So for the most part, organizations
or organizing puts us in the middle.
Another important implication is we
know a lot more about one end of this
continuum than the other. So for
example, think of physical health.
On the lefthand side, we'd call that
illness. I got the flu, I got diabetes,
I got a heart disease.
90% of all medical research focuses on
the gap between the left hand side in the
middle. It's right and five six,
five meal. If I'm having difficulty,
I will get studied. There will be
pharmaceutical products produced for me.
People will do all kinds of
tests as soon as I'm healthy.
I mean I get a physical exam once
in a while, but for the most part,
medical science doesn't
pay much attention me.
So we know a lot more about the
lefthand side than the right hand side.
Another important implication,
excuse me,
is that hardly any research is done
in psychology on anything except the
lefthand side of that continuum.
So for example, physical,
uh,
physical health gets a lot of attention,
but psychological health gets a lot
of attention to, for the most part,
psychologists are in a business.
95% of publications focus
on schizophrenia. Stress,
depression, anxiety.
I'm not doing so well.
Emotional difficulties.
That's where we focus.
But see on the right hand
side of that continuum,
there is something called
positively deviant health.
Physically it's Olympic fitness levels,
5% body fat for man,
15% body fat for women.
The ability to run an ironman competition.
How many different than me?
You know, some research,
not much psychologically it's similar.
Some years ago there was a book
written called flow. It was about,
describes a condition where you're
so immersed in a task you care about,
you lose track of time, you lose track
a physiological needs if you're using,
if you put electrodes on your brain,
you're using more of your brain
capacity than normal sounds.
Zoning out in front of a screen. It's
hyper activity mentally. Not much.
Research on that a little bit.
Not much.
So there is positively deviant phenomena.
We just don't pay much attention to it.
Organizationally,
it's very similar.
If you go to the business school
at the University of Michigan,
many of the courses, half the courses
probably will hand you a case study.
The normal assignment is, all right, what
are the issues? What are the challenges?
What has gone wrong? Come up with some
recommendations and defend yourself.
I went, how are we going to make money?
How are we gonna overcome the competition?
And so on that as we go from the left
hand side to the middle just fine,
but on the right hand side
there is positively deviant
organization performance.
Now there are several important
implications of thinking
of the right hand side
of that continuum. I refer to the
right hand side as abundance gaps.
I refer to left hand side as deficit gap,
problem solving gaps, challenge gaps.
Almost everything we study is focused
on the left hand side of the continuum.
On the right hand side,
I refer to that end of the
continuum as a virtuous condition.
Now virtuousness as a concept is not
really acceptable in scholarly rigorous
circumstances to religious,
too philosophical,
but in the original Latin and Greek
virtuousness just means the best of the
human condition.
The highest aspirations we have
for sales is a virtuous state.
So when you were at your
very best at your peak,
that's virtuousness see and music
virtuosos are the most or the best,
most inspiring performers.
Virtuosity. In fact,
if the world was virtuous, there
would be no war, no poverty,
everybody be well educated.
It's the best we can imagine.
So the whole point of this
introduction is to get to this slide
that is to separate problem solving
deaths, the gaps from abundance scabs.
Here's the most important point.
When you focus on abundance gaps,
you unleash something called
the heliotropic effect.
Do you know what the heliotropic effect
is? You do. You just don't know you do.
You put a plant in the window. Over time,
it will lean toward the light. All right,
which is an example of the heliotropic
effect, which is defined as follows.
Every living system,
everything alive has a tendency toward
the light and away from dark or toward
positive energy, away from
negative energy. See, in nature,
the sun is the source of positive
energy is so life giving force,
so most accurately defined the heliotropic
effect is every living system has a
tendency toward that which is life
giving and away from that which is life
depleting. Now that
makes sense, doesn't it?
You think of evolutionary
processes over time,
every species is attracted to that which
gives life and is repelled or avoids
that which endangers or detracts
from life. Now, if that's true,
if every human being not to mention
every system, every living system,
every human being flourishes,
and the presence of the positive and
languages in the presence of the negative,
it has big implications for
how we rear our children,
what kind of incentive systems
we have in organizations,
how we treat our colleagues,
how we manage the folks
who report to us and so on.
So what I want to do
is try to prove to you,
convince you that the
heliotropic effect exists.
And then if it does, then we're
going to talk about therefore what,
what's the relevance to Google,
to parents,
to colleagues, to friends. So just, um, I,
I'm going to share with
you a very small percent,
maybe one or 2% of the research available.
So very little,
but a few studies.
So here's one study.
Let's assume that I am a researcher
and you are all students.
But let's say you're 10 years old. Just
a normal, every do group of students.
I have three teachers who
are naive to the experiment.
They don't know this an experiment, but
it is. So I say to teacher number one,
look,
we have a group of students in this
class are incredibly bright Iq points off
the church.
They are really aggressive students.
It's going to take a great teacher to
help these kids flourish. Can you do it?
You Bet.
Teacher number two of group of students
in this class who I've enormous
diversity of ability levels,
some really smart,
similarly challenged lots in,
it's going to take a great teacher to
handle real variety of ability levels.
Can you do it?
Sure.
Teacher number three of a group of
students in this class who come from
difficult backgrounds, failed a
lot, struggled, have not done well.
It's going to take a great teacher to
help these kids flourish. Can you do it?
Sure. Then I simply asked the
teachers to teach for one year.
Now the students are all the same.
I simply asked the teachers to
teach for one year, same subject.
At the end of the year,
I give all the students a standardized
test and I find statistically significant
differences in the results.
Who scores the best
above average scores?
Average scores below average scores of,
I think I'm teaching geniuses.
I am.
I've learned from US army generals
with whom I spend several days a year,
60% of the outcome of navy seals training,
army ranger training,
special forces training is due to
the expectation of the instructor.
It's called the Pygmalion effect happens
with airline pilots all the way through
preschoolers learning shapes and
colors. All right, that's one study.
Another study done here on our campus
has been replicated several times,
so a physician puts a drop of liquid
at the bottom of your nostril in which
there's cold virus, they call it
rhino virus. You breathe in the virus,
some people get sick and some people
don't and the question is will how do you
explain who succumbs to the
virus and gets a call versus not?
Turns out the temperature at the back
of your throat where you were sofic is
neat,
meets your nasal passages a half a degree
difference in air temperature causes
you to succumb or the virus versus be
resilient and your emotional state affects
the temperature. Happy, optimistic,
positive people become six significantly
less often half as often as depressed,
angry,
cynical people.
But the classic study that illustrates
this is called the nun study.
It's a study of 678 Catholic
nuns living in a convent.
Now, this was originally designed
as an Alzheimer's disease study,
so these women were between the ages
of 75 and 104 and some of them and
Alzheimer's disease, but see they
have the same diet, same regimen,
same environment. You can control
for a lot of factors. Well,
there was a side finding that emerged
from that research and here it is.
I was especially interesting to me they
found the journals or diaries of 180 of
these women when they entered
the convent 60 years before.
Some of these women are saying
things like this in their journal.
This is a culmination of my life's dream.
I'm so happy to enter the order.
This is such a blessing. Some are saying
this is going to be a real challenge,
going to be a sacrifice, going to
be difficult, but I'm committed.
I'm going to follow through difference.
They simply put nuns in two groups,
depending on which type of type
of journal they were keeping.
Then the study was at the end of 60 years,
they simply counted the number
of nuns alive in each group.
Now,
these numbers aren't precise,
but they are very close and they represent
the difference of the 90 nuns in the
first group. 70 real live of the
90 [inaudible] in the second group,
20 were alive and at every decade.
There's a significant
difference in mortality rates.
13 years difference as it turns out,
I mean, you live longer on that happy,
optimistic, positive
perspective. Now the study,
let's assume that for a minute,
I'm interested in having all of you become
better bowlers. B. O w. L. All right,
and I'm so committed to this. I'm going
to give you a big incentive. In fact,
my power,
I'll give you $1,000 if you can improve
your bowling score by an average of 10
pins. All right? Pretty good
incentive. The challenges,
I'm going to give you only 30 days,
so we got to get a baseline.
We're all going to go
down and bowl three games.
I'm going to film you as
you bowl then for you folks.
I'm going to show you
when you were bullying.
I'm going to show you only when you made
strikes and spares when you're knocked
all the pins down. Okay? I'm going
to show you when you were bullying.
I'm going to show you only when you
did not make strikes and spares,
so square up. Work on your
approach. Try to improve. All right?
30 days later we come back together. We
all go down and bowl. Three more games.
Some of you get the money
who'd get the money?
These folks who get the money.
The question is why?
Why would these folks do better?
Just by watching themselves make strikes
versus these who are trying to improve.
That's kind of easy and
then getting comfortable.
I'm getting confident and stuff except
think about this the first time you're
not in played basketball.
Then she mostly miss.
What didn't you learn how to miss? Because
most of the data's coming back wrong.
First time when the golf
course went this way, this way,
first time in a tennis court bounced off
your racket went over there in the net.
Why didn't you learn how to do it wrong?
The answer is heliotropic effect.
Inherent in your DNA is a
tendency to learn the positive.
If you didn't, you wouldn't be
this old. You would've died before.
Now you would not have adapted
so you don't have to choose.
I'm going to show you in a minute.
You don't have to choose.
You have an inherent inclination.
It is in your DNA.
I showed you a picture of
a cell and that last slide,
it's at every cell in your
body has receptors to light.
When it's turned transforms
into life giving energy.
It's at the cellular DNA level.
The heliotropic effect has an n,
eh,
creates an inclination in all
of us toward the positive.
I'll show you some more data and just
a minute. One more. One more study.
I used to do this in my classes.
I don't do it anymore,
but it's done all over the world.
That's assume all of you are in my Mba
class at the University of Michigan and I
say to you, okay, students in my class,
you are required to keep a journal and
you have to write in your journal every
day, okay? However,
you folks every day are going to write
in your journal three things for which
you're grateful.
All right,
so five minutes before
you go to bed tonight,
just write down the three best
things that happened here.
Today are three things
for which you're grateful.
You write down three events or three
things that were frustrating or problems
you faced, so I got a journal group.
I've got a gratitude journal group.
All right. Now at the end of the
semester, I'm going to do several studies.
All of these studies are published.
For example,
I'm going to give all of you a flu shot.
Seven days later.
I'm going to test for the number
of antibodies in your system.
You're going to be healthier in seven
days detectable. He physically healthier,
more antibodies in your body.
Then are you now look,
this is a gratitude journal.
It's putting yourself in a virtuous or
in this case and gratitude condition.
Once a day I can get a
physical difference. This
is not something difficult.
This is not losing weight or giving up
coffee or training for a marathon or
something. This is put yourself
in a virtuous condition. Another,
I give you a mental acuity test. What's
that? You have to memorize information.
You have to remember information.
You have to come up with sophisticated
decision rules for complex data,
more mental acuity here than here.
I can affect your test scores.
I'm going to show you in a minute. I
give you a creativity task. What's that?
Well,
think of all the things you can use
this for or a ping pong ball or a brick.
More ideas here and a broader
variety of ideas here.
It's called mental
flexibility here than here.
This is a gratitude journal. This is,
this is a pretty easy intervention.
There's a study done about six months
ago now as the first they say claim its
own. Only one of its kind.
I can detect if you have,
if you have heart disease and
the basis of blood chemistry.
I'm not a medical doctor, so I don't
know how that works. But that's,
that's apparently the case.
So what they did is took heart disease
patients and he simply put them in two
groups once a control group.
The other one,
they asked them to keep gratitude
journals for eight weeks every day.
At the end of eight weeks,
they simply tested blood chemistry.
Those people are keeping gratitude.
Journals were healthier,
their blood chemistry was healthier
than those who did not. I mean,
they said, holy cow, first study of
its kind to show that kind of evidence.
And then I've learned
from these military folks,
if you lose a spouse to death or divorce,
zero deep depression,
six months later here,
30% deep depression here six months later.
So the whole notion is this virtuous
positive practices has physical
differences, cognitive differences,
academic differences and so on.
I'll show you some more.
Um, earlier this year,
I was on a group of,
I had a chance to select the best doctoral
dissertation done in the plant on the
planet in this general area.
This is the winner done by guy who went
to Butan and he selected high schools,
so he had 11 high schools in
an experimental condition,
nine high schools in a control condition
would that mean in 11 high schools?
He changed the curriculum so students
were exposed to virtuousness positive
practices,
positivity and so on.
He then measured one year
later and then two years later,
simply a measure of wellbeing. How you
doing? You're feeling good about yourself.
Do you like school? You're getting along
with your friends and so on. Wellbeing,
significant improvement in those,
exposed to this positive stuff.
Then here was the real surprise.
He then measured scores
on standardized tests.
Now in America that would be sat,
act tests, significant differences.
A year later, two years later,
academically they perform better.
The only differences are getting
exposed to positive practices.
Then you went to Mexico,
approximately 70,000
students in that study.
That is 35 high schools in each condition,
experimental condition,
control condition, significant
improvement, wellbeing,
academic performance.
Then he went to Peru,
700,000 students,
347 schools in each condition.
Significant differences,
and we can affect your test scores.
I mean,
virtuousness actually has an
impact. And here's, here's why.
There are interesting studies
done of heart rhythms.
So for example, I have a good friend
at an organization called heart math.
They study heart rhythms in
a frustrated, angry, upset,
depressed condition.
Your heart rhythms are very unpredictable.
Go like this. In a positive
virtuous state, like for example,
inducing gratitude. Your heart rhythms go
like this. You don't have to choose it.
It's heliotropic.
So now you know why after 60 years,
some nuns are alive in some are dead.
Their heart just works better.
Another study,
they simply ask people to contemplate,
ponder a positive,
optimistic future versus a
neutral or negative future.
So now I have you in a mental set.
Now I'm going to put you through
an MRI machine and scan your brain.
Turns out those in the positive,
optimistic mental set had more areas
of your brain activated and have those
activated. They're activated to
a great extent, greater extent.
You literally are smarter in
that positive virtuous state.
You don't have to choose it.
It's heliotropic your brain works better.
And that virtuous positive state,
sorry I don't have these slides
to show you a another study.
The, excuse me, the
um,
there was a study done of
a kidney dialysis patients,
people who were hooked up to a kidney
dialysis machine so they can't go
anywhere. And the question
is, um, I'm either,
the assignment was we want some of you
to receive a phone call from other people
expressing love,
support and concern.
And we doubled that is you're going to
receive a phone call for some people and
for some people we want you to
place a phone call expressing love,
support and concern.
At the end of that period of time.
At the end of a two year period of time,
those people who had placed a phone call,
those people who had received support
and love and concern from other people
were significantly better off than
those who did not. And here's the,
here's the explanation for them.
If you are significantly overweight,
the probability of dying early is
20% if you are an excessive drinker,
probably dying early,
30% my MBA students always want to know
what the definition of excessive means.
If you're a smoker,
probability of dying early,
50% if you are in poor
social relationships,
probably of dying early,
70% bad social relationships,
Trump,
the physical factors we
normally pay attention to.
I mean it matters a lot and there's a
whole bunch of research that suggests that
that's the case. If you're in a
conflicting, difficult relationship,
you're going to have a hard time.
That is your body for many reasons is not
going to be, it's not going to do well.
All right,
well
the question is why is that?
Well,
most of the time we say, well
it's because um, you know,
I'm getting my needs met. I
mean, I want to be popular. I,
it feels good to have somebody care
for me and so on, except that's not,
that's not the explanation.
Here's the explanation.
A and these studies were all done in our,
in our university.
So I have a colleague who's
a psychologist who, um,
took entering freshmen at the
interview or University of Michigan.
These are all 17, 18, 19 year old kids.
She simply asked them to identify
their goals for the year.
Now everyone has lots of goals,
but she categorized the
goals into two types.
One type recalled achievement
goals. I want a good, good grades,
want to be popular. I want a girlfriend,
I want to make the team and so on.
The other kind of goal was
called contribution goals.
I want to make a difference.
I want to have something get better
because of what I've contributed.
Now she put people into groups depending
on which type of goal was dominant.
Then the study was you simply followed
these students for a approximately a year
academic year measuring things like how
well they get along with her roommates,
how many minor physiological symptoms they
experienced, the cold headache, nausea,
flew, cramps, stuff like that.
How many times they miss class,
what their grade point average was,
how many times they made the team or got
elected to a club office or something.
See social factors,
academic factors,
physical factors on
every single dimension.
Contribution, goals, trumped achievement
goals in predicting performance.
It's what they contributed more
than what they got. Second,
uh,
this is one of my favorite studies is
a study of multiple sclerosis patients.
These folks,
half of them were assigned to place
a phone call once a week to somebody.
Half of them were asked to receive a
phone call from somebody once a week,
two years later they measured wellbeing.
You can see on the right hand side of
this slide, self efficacy, confidence,
competence, physical
activity, hope, depression.
Those who placed the phone call or eight
times healthier at the end of two years
than those who received the phone call.
It was the contribution because
them to flourish physically.
Um, you know, um,
borders bookstore used to be in Anarbor
now bankrupt world's largest book seller.
While they were in business,
they created the borders foundation.
The borders foundation was simply a
unit within borders where you could
contribute money and if people had a
sick child or an accident or needed
financial support,
you could apply to the borders foundation.
Get results are get a financial support.
When of our doctoral students did it,
did a study,
the hypothesis of which was if you
have received money from the borders
foundation, loyalty, commitment,
engagement will go sky high.
It turns out no difference if you receive
money, if you hadn't received money,
didn't matter.
What did matter was the opportunity to
contribute to the borders foundation.
If you had given money to the borders
foundation, commitment, loyalty,
skyhigh borders is bankrupt.
The Borders Foundation will not die.
Still exists.
Now they're trying to get mom and pop
bookstores around the country to join who
don't have safety nets.
People will not stop giving if they
have a chance to give turns out.
Contribution in relationships
is the predictor.
So when we think about positive
leadership, it's not, I want to be famous,
I want to get,
make sure you give me things.
It rather is what can I contribute to
the wellbeing or flourishing of other
people?
And there's a whole bunch of ways to
think about doing that because almost all
organizations, when you do
especially well give you stuff,
you given him financial incentive,
you get your picture on the wall,
gives you some recognition and a
newsletter. You, you're a receiver.
Turns out if you have an opportunity
to give or contribute to somebody else,
that's a much better incentive. Like for
example, if mark does especially well,
I'm going to ask him to coach somebody
else because they need to become as good
as he is. That is his reward as
he get a chance to teach or coach.
That's just one example of Manny
that you can use to contribute in
organizations. Okay, and
I'm going to skip these now.
The question is,
all right,
I got the brainwaves camera
and I got the heart rhythms,
rhythms and all that stuff.
Okay? But wait a minute.
Organizations are much more
complex than our individuals.
That as you can get a bunch
of happy people together,
does not make for a great organization.
So the question is,
does this actually work in organizations
when I'm held accountable for
profitability and productivity and quality
and customer satisfaction and so on.
That's been my research for 15 years.
That's been the question. Yeah,
but does it work in organizations?
Turns out after 15 years.
The bottom line is if you implement
in an organization positive practices,
we haven't talked about
what that is at all,
but virtuous practices,
compassion, kindness,
uh, forgiveness, gratitude and so on,
you will get higher
levels of profitability.
You make more money by
far than the industry.
Average productivity is
significantly improved.
Quality goes up, fewer errors, fewer,
fewer, less waste, fewer mistakes,
innovation, new product ideas, creativity,
all improve the scores on creativity
go up, customer satisfaction,
customer loyalty,
customer retention goes up,
employee satisfaction and employee
retention. I'll go up. That is,
that's what you're held accountable for.
All of those are significantly improved
when you implement positive practices.
I'm going to not show you
hardly any of their search,
but let me just give
you a couple of studies.
One of the most surprising studies is
this one because we said where is the
least likely place anybody
would care about this? Positive,
virtuous, Saccharin, sweet,
soupy, syrupy touchy,
feely,
naive pollyannish stuff.
Likely Wall Street.
I mean if I got $100 million invested
in that portfolio and I'm going to hedge
fund, I want to know if it's going
up or down cause I got one goal.
Show me the money. That's all
I care about. I don't care
if you treat people well.
I don't care if you downsize, I don't
care if you, I don't care what you do.
I want to return.
So it picked 40 firms when
they implemented positive
practice or some did better
than others. Should we measured
change or in other words,
how are you getting better? You're getting
worse. You're staying in the shame.
When organizations improved,
gotten more and more virtuous,
essentially we could account for
almost 50% 0.45% 45% of their financial
performance. Now, I dunno,
anything that predicts Wall
Street performance by 45%
but we could plus a bunch
of other things to turn over and you know,
satisfaction and all
those kinds of things.
That is even in the least likely
a most hostile environment.
You can imagine positive performance has
paid off and then in healthcare you'd
sort of expect that,
but over a two year period of time,
double digit improvement where the
industry average is one or 2% double digit
improvement on these various dimensions
that really count that people want to
improve.
So the whole point is with only a very
small sampling of the information,
what we know is actually positive
practices pay off physically,
cognitively, socially, and they pay off.
Organizationally when you
implement positive practices,
organizations do better.
Where we improve what we want, what
we're held accountable for, oh,
we want to improve.
All right,
there's a bunch of resources that are
available if you want to get them.
There's a website that we have for our
research center where there's long lists
of videos and references and papers and
syllabi for courses and all those kinds
of things.
And that I'm going to stop
here because I've just, uh,
I've just talked for 32
minutes. Questions, comments,
yeah,
buts anything on your mind.
Hey, my name is Dominique. Um,
and I do have a question about if
you've ever stood a study on Google.
I feel like all of the brackets you talked
about and positive leadership and are
quite a few of our pillars. I think our
senior leadership takes pretty seriously.
Have you ever looked at a study on here?
Never
done it. I've never done a study on
Google. I'd love to. Just was curious.
I
read a lot.
I would like to get my prediction.
I'll finish the thought.
My prediction is that there are
pockets that are spectacular,
extraordinary and pockets that are,
could be improved, I would guess.
And one of the nice things about starting
Google is to try to find out where
those are and what the practices are
specifically here that would create the
spectacular performance. Um, uh,
I am so far there is no disconfirming
evidence that this pays off and
organizations so far I'm not going to
disconfirming evidence about anything but
not this.
Thanks.
First of all, thank you for coming
out here and speaking to us. Um,
I was wondering if you had a similar
to the question about Google,
but have you done any research or,
but we're on like nonprofits
and those who work there, um,
or maybe are in some sort
of service jobs such as, um,
nursing or fire firemen, you
know, just helping the community.
Yeah,
that's really good question.
How about not for profits and turns out
we've done a lot of work in the f and
the following industries.
There's a lot of work in education that
is implementing these positive practices,
changes, test scores, changes,
academic performance and so on.
We've done a lot of work in healthcare.
I showed you one little quick study of
that, uh, of that. And, and hospitals.
We've done a lot of work in the
national intelligence agencies, CIA,
FBI, Nsa, Dia, 16 agencies.
See you can't manufacture enough
bullets to keep the world safe Kenyon.
So they've gotta be some alternatives.
They get it.
And it's been pretty inspirational to me
to see how the FBI is trying to figure
out a way to implement positive practices
or positive leadership. You know,
so that's another military army generals,
especially US army generals.
I'm not working on any, you know, the
noncommissioned officers and so on.
But from the one, two, three, four
star level, boy, I tell you what their,
um,
I'm impressed with them from
their perspective setting
strategy for the world.
This resonates and matters.
So they've been working on this for
seven or eight or nine years, you know,
this whole topic.
Um,
so that we did a big
study of nursing nurses,
similar kind of outcome with the
nursing care and probably some others,
but there's a lot of not for
profit, um, work that's being done.